je suis de droite et progressif je suis
gaulliste et progressistes mais surtout
je vois pas comment on peut faire
autrement
[Musique]
surtout comment ne pas l'être assez ça
la vraie question quand vous regardez
l'histoire du 20e siècle c'est une c'est
une série de génocide de plus en plus
atroces les uns que les autres ans elle
commence avec les herreros en 1905 par
les allemands ça se termine par les
hutus et les tutsis et entre temps on a
une série de génocide les juifs les
arméniens les cambodgiens donc quand les
lèveraient réactionnaire les
réactionnaires intelligent dinars
c'était mieux avant je voudrais revenir
avant mais à quoi ils voudraient revenir
j'ai le premier garçon dans ma famille à
partir faire la guerre il regardez
regardez l'europe l'europe même dans les
années 70 dans les années 60 c'est la
révolution culturelle chinoise ses 70
millions de bord les années 70 et en
amérique latine c'est la catastrophe
absolue c'est des dictatures
sanguinaires au coeur de l'europe vous
avez encore franco vous allez le
portugal et la grèce sont des dictatures
les pays de l'est sont sous la botte
soviétique enfin je veux dire je vois
pas vers quoi je pourrais revenir avant
et si je veux dire les choses
positivement maintenant pourquoi je suis
progressiste trois révolutions génial la
révolution scientifique les lumières le
xviiie siècle comment ne pas être un
héritier des lumières quand on est de
droite et un possible deuxième
révolution ce que j'ai appelé la
révolution de l'amour la fondation de la
famille moderne sur le mariage d'amour
et non plus le mariage arrangé le
mariage de raison formidable progrès et
troisième révolution qui va avec la
deuxième la révolution des femmes je
n'ai aucune envie de vivre dans un monde
où les femmes sont voilées ou elles
suivent leurs maris à trois mètres
derrière il n'y a pas d'homme libre sans
femme libre et donc je n'ai aucune envie
de revenir à un monde où les femmes
n'avaient pas le droit de vote où elle
était enfermée dans la domesticité et
donc ces trois révolutions sam interdit
absolument d'imaginer vivre dans un
autre monde que celui d'aujourd'hui ça
veut pas dire qu'il n'a pas de défauts
comme ministre de l'éducation j'ai vu la
montée des idées à des incivilités j'ai
vu la montée l'illettrisme et c'est pas
irréversible on peut faire quelque chose
tandis que dans le monde d'avant ne
pouvait rien faire et donc oui
évidemment je suis de droite et
progressif je suis gaulliste est
progressif mais surtout je vois pas
comment on peut faire autrement
vraie droite réactionnaire qui dit
c'était mieux avant on va revenir à
l'époque où les femmes étaient
bâillonnées où elle n'avait pas le droit
de vote et c'est donc il ya une pensée
réactionnaire qui peut être très fort
d'ailleurs qu'il peut être parfois très
intelligente mais mais mais qui est
quand même fondamentalement à mes yeux
très bête parce que la vérité c'est que
je ne vois pas quelle époque du monde on
pourrait revenir on pourrait souhaiter
revenir aucun d'entre nous ne souhaite
ça en vérité donc c'est en vérité une
posture alors évidemment qu'il ya des
choses qui était mieux avant évidemment
qu'on peut avoir mené la nostalgie de
l'époque où les enfants étaient bien
élevé et gentil et qu'ils avaient fait
des bonnes études et/ou une tâche
n'était pas là évident que la
catastrophe absolue aujourd'hui c'est
l'islamisme mais à part à part la
constatation des traits maléfique ou
mauvais de la modernité fin ne justifie
en rien le retour en arrière